they are the champions yeah okay my
friends yeah so tonight Las Vegas is
celebrating their WNBA
NBA the parade down Las Vegas Boulevard
the chance for us all to congratulate
the aces is the city's first major pro
sports championship Candace Charles is
on Las Vegas Boulevard with some details
on the party
well good morning to you again morning
folks grab your red black and gold
because you're invited to the strip
tonight for a huge celebration for our
first Major League champions that's
right the iconic log Vegas Aces the WNBA
Champion brought the trophy home after
beating the Connecticut Suns our sports
team club put them after the window
sharing the excitement and they say
they're ready for you guys tonight your
Sixth Man is really your fans and so we
can't thank our fans enough and we hope
to see them on Tuesday evening as we
shut down the strip that was Aces
president Nikki Fargo's calling you out
for one of the biggest celebrations in
recent Sports history happening right
here on the ship tonight now this is the
map of the route the organization will
take a short trip from Caesars to the
Bellagio Fountains where there will be a
huge celebration now ask our County why
the route is so short I was told that's
exactly how the aces wanted they want to
celebrate with you right there in front
of the Bellagio Fountains for that huge
rally on traffic on the southbound Lanes
of Las Vegas Boulevard will be closed
captioning
not
available
at standard rates as usual but arrive
early to find a spot and of course we
got you covered with merch so be two
pop-up shops where you can get your Aces
gear one today from nine to one at
Findlay Toyota in Henderson of course
we'll have all those details for you on
8newsnow.com and of course we've got you
covered with live coverage so stick with
us right here on air on Lionel social
for the latest for now from Las Vegas
strip I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now